down three-pointers his defense brings  toughness  not afraid of the assignment going  against kevin durant  here's durant off the double gets it out  to harris backs it up for a three-point  attack  one rebound is handled by middleton and  you can see the length of milwaukee in  their defense  chris middleton takes all the way and  middleton right there elongating to the  basket  and it looked like durant frustration  turned the ball over inbound in the ball  step over the line i think it might have  hit the backboard i'm not sure  maybe a little frustrated there where pj  tucker  got that steal a few possessions before  but  the length of milwaukee the way they can  cover the court  and close out to shooters presents all  types of problems for brooklyn and their  offense all right here's another  oh yes you're right brad hit the uh the  back  of the of the glass